сама тут запалилася аполітична кар'єра
франсуа фійон am sorry дарують кулі в
західної Франції
мої так dbc 12 століттям свого
елегантний сімейний пляшок на барезі
річці сарт він іванич кому фермерському
селище шаблею сирс art франсуа фійон
проти мером болото
кидаєте вояку відомого насіння і на чому
я не заполірована скандалами
для мене франсуа фійон на ebay сільський
кандидату президенти
ми бачили queen тут став політиком
валовий у нашого вибір чого округу а
потім і всього регіону теж ми знаємо у
джова вінда зберегти ці фермери мішель
даттон і бачений при хільні
консервативного кандидата в президенти та
буду за нього голосувати і назва жінок
астане скандал і способи його сина Петра
мою тихо та каталозі keys приймають
батька п'ють і dtx в брухт при всьому про
місяців і священик визнаємо фійон
вдалося і прям активно по передніх
виборах республіканців сам і завдяки
поляризованим католиком та франція
християн і віку за взята проживають свою
віру це було ви дно піджак демонстрації
проти 1 статті вахш любимо у Франції
c групи каталозі столітті бояться but і
політично маргіналізовані ми і про
град і парфененко турі в один фійон
будина легкого 33 прочитання католицьких
вибір тиф спливають усинові панова чого
не проти дружини кандидата у президенти
відбуваються з чого то й іди ти зарубала
moi je мільйон євро зарплати на
ефективних посадок не здійснить і
лежаків any person ніхто у нашого села
ще на мить на я ж витягну його
навпроти алан вони вам ніхто не коли немає
шоу про це
а у франції ми кожному рахунок мати гарна
жити а
потрібно 1000 прихід і хоча фійону
багата круто кують за місяць до виборів
forbore мішель даттон завищується вірним
свого до зайвого сусіда і там феномен
alpine
ми не душі skoda їх об бік особливо його
дружину вона мабуть душа страждає
для нього кандидата президенти фійон
завищуються сином з землі і дала типу
ризики скандали на чи в полоні на c